c'est quoi ce bordel ça fait des mois
que je vaux pas de smartphone à écran
pliable en vous disant les smartphones à
écran pliable c'est la révolution c'est
l'avenir
le where he bol les écrans qui se plie
on va retrouver partout sur les
vêtements les chaussures partout c'est
vraiment génial et la baule à karine le
tout premier smartphone à écran pliable
et je vous dit pas l'acheter non à l'eau
non mais à l'eau bon allez je vous
explique pourquoi
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez vu ce smartphone
alors là bas et j'ai noté la de ce que
je peux pas tout appris par coeur un ses
rôles
cellflex paye le flex paye le flex paye
je suis encore dubitatifs
je suis très très très très comment dire
je suis surexcitée parler d'avoir des
smartphones et des écrans pliables
trouve que le concept est génial parce
que on va davantage vers la
miniaturisation des objets mais par des
écrans encore plus grands alors comment
on fait pour faire entrer des écrans
encore plus grand dans des objets en
plus petit il ya un moment ça marche pas
vous avez des smartphones qui sont quand
même grand aujourd'hui je dois pas se
mentir on a des écrans même de quasiment
la des trucs quasiment 7 pouces par un
moment bon c'est énorme mais on veut des
formats petit pratiques simples et
justement vous ai parlé beaucoup de
samsung qui travaillent dessus depuis
des années sur le fameux galaxy x voilà
que huawei est arrivé dans la course à
quelques mois et on en parlait il ya
quelques mois mais longtemps j'imagine
qu'ils travaillent dessus qu'on sort pas
un smartphone avec un écran pliable
comme ça papa fond de moi donc je me dis
que tu rêves depuis très longtemps
dessus et pour l'instant du côté de ces
deux entreprises en tout cas on n'a rien
vu arriver
il ya des choses vous déjà un petit peu
futés d'autres marques porte à gauche
mais il n'y a pas eu de produits
officiels et la voilà qui est annoncé
le premier smartphone à écran pliable
chinois et non je vous déconseille
fortement d'aller dessus
non pas parce que le concept n'est pas
bon mais parce que ce produit n'a tout
simplement pas bon pas la hauteur trop
cher pour ce que c'est je vous explique
le flex paye de riols c'est dur à
prononcer fleckstein brouillonne bon ce
smartphone à écran pliable chinois de la
marque rougeole n'est pas fait pour être
vendus au grand public par la marque
je pense pas qu'ils vont pouvoir
fabriquer énormément d'unités pour
arroser le monde entier très clairement
de toute façon dû le marché des écrans
pliables n'est pas mûre je pense que
pour ça même les grands industriels tels
que samsung propose encore un petit peu
la question de comment positionner leurs
produits et qu'elle est arrêtée c'est ça
pour l'instant il ya eu des proto mais
sont pas complètement sûr leur proto
donc on y va doucement il ya déjà ce
point là je pense qu'au contraire la
marque royal cherche à faire un coup à
faire parler d'elle en avant-première
parce qu'elle sent qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attentes et notamment des technophiles
comme moi et comme beaucoup d'autres qui
ont vraiment hâte de voir cette techno
arrivée et bord à quoi ça va ressembler
donc ils sont des si on sort tout de
suite
un smartphone avec un écran pliable
juste avant 2019 alors en 2019 devrait
arriver les modèles de huawei et de
samsung pourrait faire un coup on fait
parler de nous à l'échelle planétaire
niveau international tout le monde parle
de nous c'est d'ailleurs le cas puisque
on est en train de le faire tout de
suite ça leur parle effectivement de
capitaliser pour leur entreprise ce qui
sont cotées en bourse ça j'en sais
absolument rien dans tout cas de
capitaliser en montrant qu'ils sont
vraiment capables de sortir des produits
innovants avant tout le monde donc ça
pour le business pour eux c'est très
très bon j'ai encore des doutes sur la
qualité du produit non pas sur la techno
une fois de plus mais sur leurs
solutions à eux mêmes si certains
smartphones du standard je n'irai pas
l'acheter
cette marque pas trop trop forcément
confiance tout de suite comme ça je le
reconnais pas parce que le produit n'est
pas cadeau cadeaux avant de parler du
prix et je vais vous présenter ce
produit explique un petit peu ce qu'il a
sous le capot à quoi il ressemble quels
sont les points qui me font un petit peu
douté alors d'un point de vue design
déjà je trouve vraiment pas bon je
trouve que il n'est pas très bien
intégré et effectivement vous allez tout
une grande partie avec un un écran
pliable avec une charnière au centre
jusqu'à la techno est plutôt standard et
ça marche plutôt bien
par contre sur le côté ils vous ont fait
une espèce de grande langue est grosse
bordures avec l'intégration d'un double
module photo il ya probablement pas mal
de composants importants à l'intérieur
c'est pas très bien intégré c'est pas
très beau je ne sais pas ce que
proposeront les autres industriels du
samsung et du wawel est en tout cas ça
je trouve vraiment que c'est pas très
très bien réussi et vous avez en plus
des grandes bord sur le haut sur le bas
bon voilà ce qui attend encore un petit
peu dubitatif là dessus alors le produit
est un peu lourd il fait 320 g je ne
sais pas ce que pourra faire la
concurrence là dessus j'imagine qu'on
sera probablement dans cette gamme de
poêles à 250 grammes 300 g
bon pas cracher dans la soupe là dessus
les annonces que l'écran pourra s'ouvrir
et se fermer 200 mille fois alors je
vais pas le faire deux cent mille fois
là parce que ça ferait quand même
beaucoup
deux cent mille fois sans aucun problème
on rassure un petit peu sur la techno
faut savoir que vous avez c'est le mx3
des chiots me situe pas de bêtises ils
ont dit qu'il faut nourrir 300 mille
fois le clap est donc bon de 200 des
fois why not
en termes de pertes la fiche technique
je trouve assez fou une 10 on a à
l'intérieur un qualcomm snapdragon de la
série 8 alors la série 8
c'est un dragon c'est la série la plus
haut de gamme mais lequel lequel on sait
pas on sait qu'il est cadencé jusqu'à 2
8 giga hertz mais pas lieu on nous
annonce qu'il est gardé dans cette
nanomètres avec de l'intelligence
artificielle ça c'est bien mais pas bien
et on y dit également qu'il pourrait
supporter la 5g c'est bien c'est très
très bien pour l'instant la scène jane
est pas encore là je pense que ce point
là une fois de plus est vraiment là pour
faire un coup de boost au niveau des
professionnels pour dire 'regardez ont
un smartphone pliable et en plus il
singe est compatible voilà on nous
annonce de version 16 giga de ram 8
gigas de ram
alors que sur le site d'une avec la
version 6 giga de ram de commercialiser
on nous annonce trois versions stockage
128 256 512 alors que vous n'avez que la
version 128 et 256 de commercialiser à
la 72 n'y est pas et en plus elles sont
extensible avec une carte microsd
jusqu'à 250 gigas
quel intérêt d'avoir dû 250 gigas
extensif quelque 250 gigas ou alors pire
du 512 extensible jusqu'à 256 gia je
suis pas sûr soit très pertinent au
niveau de la photo on a un double coup
du photo qui vous servira bien
évidemment pour les selles fille en tant
que caméra principale donc là dessus sur
ce pôle en réalité on fait des économies
vous avez un appareil photo de 20
mégapixels et un téléobjectif et vous
avez un grand-angle de 16 mégapixels
on nous avons une ouverture de f 1.8
normalement très lumineux au niveau de
l'écran et c'est là où ça devient très
très très intéressant vous avez un écran
de 7,8 pousse une fois qu'il est
complètement ouvert c'est une dalle
forcément flexible c'est un écran amoled
il se plie de 0 à 180 donc système comme
ça et ce qui est très intéressante et
vous avez plusieurs ratios alors je vous
explique lorsqu'il est fermé
vous avez un ratio 16 9ème sur une
partie de l'écran parce que sur une
partie l'écran vous allez avoir quand il
va être fermé vous avez la partie vous
avez la grande borat et appareil photo
et une autre partie vous n'avez pas donc
forcément vous avez deux écrans
différents sur une partie vous avez à
l'écran 16 9ème 810 par 1440 sur l'autre
vous avez un écran 18 9e 720 par 1440
est alors sur l'autre c'est à dire que
tout en haut lorsqu'il est fermé au
niveau de la charnière
vous avez un écran 21/6 oui mes amis
vous avez entendu 21/6
390 par 1440 donc il me déteste ça comme
étant trois écrans différents parce que
vous pouvez le prendre d'un côté de
l'autre l'utiliser comme un smartphone
aux côtés du lot pour répondre il a
petit parti sur le holà petit charnière
vous servira pour venir décrocher passer
des coups de fil et un des petits
raccourcis donc il ne s'est pas vraiment
en trois zones distinctes dans cette
configuration fermée vous permettra de
répondre au téléphone ou sms regarder
des vidéos sur un plus petit écran mais
ça marchera mais lorsque vous l'ouvrez
c'est là où il prend toute son ampleur
vous avez donc ce fameux écran 12 et de
7,8 pouces format 4/3 comme sur une
bonne vieille télé classique avec une
résolution de 1920 par 1440 pixels à 320
pixels par pouce pourrait donc faire
plein de choses du multitâche qui
utilisait comme une grosse table on s'y
tient notre pote qui me chagrine un
petit peu c'est l'autonomie parce que
lorsque vous regardez leur site il ya un
truc que je trouve pas très très clairs
là on parle de la batterie donc on les
en toute la zone qui va parler de la
batterie on parle normal charging fast
charge batterie est ici on vous pas de
la capacité de la batterie de 6000
millan paire eur voilà votre mail à vous
retrouver là-bas mais lorsque vous
regardez un petit peu en bas comparaison
que phonique ont par exemple pour une
heure de chars nananana n'ya en vous
marc rouillan de la borat y tester la
gagne assure la charge batterie 6000
milles et intérieure et vous voyez qu au
final le smartphone utilise une batterie
de 3810 antérieures donc la touche
devant des explications pourquoi est ce
qu'on va me faire des comparaisons sur
une batterie de 6000 milles et en paire
d'heures tout ça pour avoir une batterie
de trois mille huit cent millions
d'euros à l'intérieur il ya un truc que
je comprends pas trop alors après on a
un écran qui est énorme
cette virgule je vous ai dit combien de
fois je me perds il ya tellement de
chiffres que je sais bien du 8 pouces un
écran de 7 pouces avec une batterie de
trois mille huit cent millions terreur
vous avez derrière intérêts avoir un
logiciel complètement optimisé pour
avoir une bonne autonomie
et là dessus je suis pas sûr parce que
en termes d'os vous êtes sûrs en water
os qui repose sur un android 9 paille
je ne connais pas water os on n'a pas
été présentée j'espère qu'on le sera
prochainement chanteur aurait si tu me
regardes mais est-ce que ça va
fonctionner correctement pour avoir
quelque chose de complètement optimisé
avec cette taille d'écran je suis pas
sûr j'ai des doutes il nous annonce de
la recharge rapide
une recharge en usb type c'est ça le
papier c'est bien a ajouté que vous
aussi un casque en usb ticks et il n'y a
pas deux prises jack là dessus vous avez
double carte mono sim et qui a priori
serait uniquement compatible aujourd'hui
avec china telecom donc n'imaginais pas
à pouvoir l'utiliser en europe avec une
carte sim européenne je ne pense pas que
ça marche par contre si vous regardez
bien sur leur site
les tarifs sont marqués en euros là ici
là là en euros alors qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai voulu mener une enquête je me
suis connecté avec thor pour avoir une
ip étrangères puisque je me suis dit ça
se trouve c'est parce qu'ils repèrent
monde ip française du coup il met des
tarifs en euros je fus connecter avec
une autre ip et me voilà connecter
depuis l'angleterre
et voilà que mes tarifs sont toujours en
euros pourtant en angleterre on parle
bien en livres sterling et ce qui est
aussi très intéressant à voir c'est que
lorsque vous regardez en va ici dans la
barre des langages vous voyez
qu'effectivement vous pouvez la voir en
chinois en anglais en néerlandais en
allemand en français
pour moi ce produit n'est pas destiné
pour être vendus dans le monde entier
aux pays-bas en france en angleterre aux
etats-unis en chine et en allemagne
pour moi il est fait pour être une
vitrine et faire du business c'est aussi
une raison pour laquelle je vous
déconseille d'aller dessus aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas que ça il ya un autre point
qui me fait dire qu'il faut pas y aller
dessus vous à nous dire ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire lorsque j'arrive
sur la fiche d'achat du site flexpen
développeurs modèle donc pour moi c'est
pas du tout un produit qui est prêt tout
de suite en tout cas
pour le grand public lorsque ça c'est
spécifié nulle part donc pour moi ce
produit aujourd'hui il est pas encore
prêt pour grand public je suis sûre
quasiment sûr qu'en l'achetant vous
allez déçu parce qu'il n'est pas prêt
l'idée pour son entreprise c'était de
sortir tout de suite en avant première
avant tout le monde pour se faire un peu
de pub générer du business mais pas pour
le vendre dans le monde entier d'autant
plus qu'au terme de tarifs tout de suite
il est quand même relativement élevées
envers sursis giga +128 giga de stockage
il est à 1388 euros si vous voulez la
version toujours si giga de ram 256 go
de stockage il coûte 1500 39 euros sur
toi ce sont des tarifs hors taxes il
faut rajouter la taxe française a
vérifié s'ajoute un bémol là dessus
toutefois voulais vraiment prendre le
risque
il est disponible en précommande dès
aujourd'hui et il sera livrable à la fin
du mois de
décembre pourquoi ne pas l'acheter ben
parce que d'une la marque personne ne la
connaît en tout cas le grand public ne
la connais pas deuxièmement a priori pas
compatible avec une sim européenne
troisièmement franchement il est moche
quatrièmement les smartphones à écran
pliable devrait arriver l'année
prochaine notamment du côté de ces
samsung chez huawei donc je pense qu'on
aura des produits beaucoup plus aboutie
beaucoup plus réussie avec derrière un
vrai elle savait qu'on connaît avec des
marques sur lesquelles on sait qu'on
peut s'appuyer
mais après c'est aussi un marché de
niche pour l'instant tout de suite on
est dans une nouvelle techno qui est en
train de se développer
j'imagine que lorsque ça va vraiment
arriver à l'échelle des gros industriels
tout le monde n'aura pas de smartphone à
écran pliable faudra du temps pour ça
arrive
vous avez suivi mes vidéos sur les
écrans pliables je vous parle déjà de
where hebel je disais que pour moi lower
hebel les écrans on allait pouvoir plier
aux trouver partout sur ses vêtements
ça va être l'avenir parce qu'on a des
objets connectés je vous ai montré à
l'ifa ya pas longtemps des iu battles en
partenariat avec sony vous pouviez
synchroniser des motifs avec votre
smartphone est bonne ou baleines c'était
juste incroyable
je suis hyper jolie alors on peut aller
encore plus loin ce n'est pas tout
encore hyper abouti père fou mais on
voit qu'on avance donc et il le propose
ils ont dû opérer bol ils ont un t-shirt
avec un écran amoled pliable attendait
le prix vous n'êtes pas le t-shirt coûte
la modique somme de 1099 euros 1,99
centimes le t-shirt le principe par
machine comme ça et vous avez aussi un
chapeau à écran pliable qui l'ont
présenté pour la coupe du monde qui
exactement même tarif 1099 euros de la
gueule 99 centimes
donc ce qui est sûr dans tout ça et ce
qui est passionnant c'est qu'on voit que
les smartphones à écran pliable un livre
qu'on voit que les écrans pliables
arrive on voit qu'on va pouvoir y couper
on voit d'ici quelques années cette
technique de vraiment se démocratise et
on en comptant le temps qu'il grand
industriel se mettre dessus
cette marque c'est un coup de com c'est
un gros coup de pub ça marche
bravo c'est en tout cas le mérite
d'exister et le mérite de voir que ces
techno avance les smartphones à écran
pliable arrive c'est pas une chimère on
en parle depuis des années sur
pagesjaunes depuis depuis un petit
moment puis on voit que petit à petit ça
arrive ça se met en place
donc je vous invite à faire une chose si
ce sujet vous intéresse et bien
évidemment à vous abonner on reste
connectés parce que dès qu'on aura
d'autres infos des choses intéressantes
à se mettre sous la dent à se mettre
sous la main peut-être à vegas aux crs
en début d'année prochaine j'ai un petit
peu fouillis à droite à gauche peut-être
au mwc ce que j'irai voir ça et
je ferai un grand plaisir pour relier la
peau voilà soyez ça je vous embarque et
à très bientôt
[Musique]